HE AVERAGES 20 POINTS AWAY FROM
FEDEX FORUM.>> Quinn: HALIBURTO
FIGURES.
THAT ONE E
>> Kate: THAT IS
COFFEY THE NICE NIGIG
THESE, THE ROCKETS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SEE THE THERE
BY ACTUALLY SHOOTING THE THREE.
>>> STAY TUNED FOR WIT INSIDE
DOTTED, A FLYJACK GOING TO ATTA
HERE. HE GOES ALL L THE
BALL. HE'S LIKE IN A CHASE  COU
>> Walt: SO USE THAT FORD A
DAGGER WHEN YOUR FRIEND.
YOU CANNOT HAVE  ANY WAISTED
TO TIE THE GAME. HE'S GOT. GHT
TREY -- TO TREY CAN PUT THIS
BASKETBALL ON THE FLOOR AND IT'S
ALSO BEEN A TATE GETS WRAPPED
UP, FOULED BY HALIBURTON.
TOLD THAT HE WANTED TO GIVEDID
TOP-SHOT RIGHT THERE.
IRVING ON THE MOVOV FEARLESS.
>> Bill: THEY GOT 1.3 ON THE HA.
SHOT IN THE  ASSISTS WERE
TOWNS ROOTED AGAIN, TH IS OFF TE
CHARTS.
INCREDIBLE FOR THE NBA TRIGGER F
ALL THE TALENTS THAT WE HAVE
CONTINUE TODAY WATCH
THROUGHO
FOR THREE. AND IT GOES DOWN!ONSS
IN THIS SECOND HALF.RL MALONE A
MOVING. LEBRON SAID, HEY,